بدله كبيره اذا احدثتها دبابات ليوبارتوال
المانيه هل تعطيها المانيا ام لا وهل تسمح
لاخرين بتصيعها هذا الاسرار الاوكراني
اولا والغربي ثانيا على تزويد اكياس بهذه
الدبابات اسبابهم متعدده لكن اهم هذه
الاسباب ان لا يعتبر ستشكل نقل نوعيه في
الحرب مع منحها القوات الاوكرانيه القدره
الهجوميه وليس فقط الدفاع وصد الهجمات
الروسيه فضلا عن السهوله اللوجستيه
المانيا انت جد نحو تسعه الاف قطعه من هذه
الدبابات منذ عام
1963 ويتم تصنيع النوع نفسه في ثلاث دول
اخرى بترخيص من المانيا وتستخدمها جيوش
احدى وعشرين دوله في تشير التقديرات
مشاهدينا الحاليه الى وجود نحو الفائده في
اوروبا اكثر من 423 دبابه منها مخزنه في
الم يا وفقا للمعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه تركيا تملك 316 دبابه لوبان
تليها بولندا مع دبابتين واليونان مع 138
دبابه اما سويسرا فتمتلك همم من دبابات
اليابان
1434 او 30 دبابات وفيما لا يزال الاخذ
والرد متواصلا ابدا شركه المعدات العسكريه
همم
الالمانيه
بمائه وتسع 139 دبابه من طراز اذا لازم
الامر اضافات انه يمكن للشركه تسليم 29
دبابه بحلول اي برو او مايو واا واثنتين
و20 دبابه اخرى بحلول نهايه العام الحالي
كما اكدت مشاهدينا الشركه الالمانيه
امكانيه ارسال
88 دبابه من طراز ليوبار 1 دون تحديد
الموعد حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]